[Applause]
[Music]
2017 is the year the Canada celebrates
150 years of existence the specific day
of their birthday was the 1st of July so
well happy belated birthday Canada as
well de PUE are 150 years of existence
is not the only matter we should be
congratulating Canada on the country
reached its one hundred and fiftieth
anniversary in great shape because well
if there's something we can say about
Canada right now it's that the country
is certainly in vogue and he has Canada
is also the homeland of many celebrities
that we all know well
[Music]
laughter there has been one celebrity
who has been put in the international
political spotlight we are of course
talking about Justin no no no no no not
that Justin we meant this one of course
Justin Trudeau Canada has reached its
150th birthday as one of the richest
countries in the world with a top-notch
quality of life as well as being one of
the most admired countries on earth
certainly not bad right so now you might
be wondering what is the cause of all of
this what are the main achievements that
Canada is celebrating after 150 years
and importantly well is there a dark
side to Canada we're going to answer all
of those questions in this video but
first let us get some perspective the
great transformation you might not have
heard much about Canada recently but we
can certainly say that they are no
ordinary country in fact Canada is the
second biggest country in the world with
its territory covering six different
time zones and guess which country has
the most coastline in the world
well no prizes if you guessed Canada of
course there's all regular visual polity
viewers already know neither the size of
a country surface nor its coastline
determines its wealth or how many
opportunities its citizens have so then
what's really behind these success on
Canada well one key factor here is the
disastrous years the Canada had in the
late 80s and early 90s during this time
Canada suffered economic stagnation and
several crises these were bad enough
that in 1995 The Wall Street Journal
called Canada an honorary member of the
third world due to its inability to
control government accounts through them
as you can see things have changed
enormously Canada really knew how to
play to their strengths and get rid of
their weaknesses and especially and
above all Canadians have really
understood the importance and meaning of
these two words competitiveness and
integration
after those disastrous years of the 80s
and 90s Canadians realized that before
thinking about spending it is absolutely
essential to think about creating and
they realized that in order to do that
they needed investment businesses and
trade a great deal of trade
[Music]
[Applause]
well so as it was said so it was done
Canada is today the seventh freest
economy in the world but if we're
talking about freedom then we can't just
talk about the economic side of things
the Fraser Institute publishes every
year something called the human freedom
Index this measures both the economic
and the civil freedoms that people enjoy
quite simply it measures what we can't
do and what we can't though well
according to their research Canada is
the sixth freest country on earth give
you a better idea of how this compares
to some other countries well the USA
they ranked 23rd Italy is in at 28 and
Japan is flagging in position 32 maybe
the reason for this is the strong
decentralization that the country has
Canada it's divided into ten provinces
and 3 territories that have so many
unique regulations that in 2017 they
actually had to sign a free trade
agreement among them new interprovincial
trade deal expected to add billions to
the economy the decentralization is
absolutely enormous and it is
traditionally resulted in higher costs
for those companies that don't operate
in a single region but in several
different regions with each region
having different regulations in Ontario
petrol must be at least 5% ethanol
Manitoba insists on an 8.5% blend the
positive side of this is that this has
worked as a counterweight to the federal
governments and it's encouraged them to
make pro citizen policies and that's
something that has driven good public
policies anyway this new agreement has
been created in order to beat all these
surprising obstacles further as we
talked about in a previous video there's
also the Canadian bet on
multiculturalism and well let us be
rather Frankie nowadays this country is
one of the best examples of integration
in the entire world by huge eeka
the Canadian mosaic fossil this Canadian
multiculturalism what's it all really
about well basically it consists of
accepting that cultural diversity is not
a threat but it's an asset and a source
of opportunities for a country now of
course this multiculturalism is always
subordinate to a core set of values such
as democracy such as the rule of law and
equality for all people now this needs
that in order to be Canadian and be
welcomed into their country you don't
have to replace your culture with any
other like the Canadian culture you just
have to accept and commit to those core
Canadian values and I mean look
Canada has one of the largest
populations of immigrants in the world
one out of every five Canadians weren't
born in Canada and I mean for some
cities like Toronto this figure it grows
up to 50% or even higher and it seems
that it will be even higher in the
future because every year more than
300,000 new immigrants come to this
country which is one of the highest
immigration rates in the entire world
and you know the result of all of this
is do you think is a problem well it's
it's actually no problem at all yeah
look as we said in that previous video
immigration in Canada it's certainly not
for free there's this system that exists
that's based on three fundamental
pillars points family reunification and
refugees
[Music]
the most important one of these is the
point based system this exists do grants
people residents or work permits it
considers things like having a job offer
which is the most important thing or
also maybe having a degree or having the
ability to speak English and you want to
know the results of these policies well
almost 80% of Canadians think that
immigration is good for the economy this
is something that really shouldn't be so
strange when you consider that all the
statistics show that immigrants the
brand-new Canadians are more educated
they work more hours they create more
businesses and they draw less dollars
from social programs now the question
might be does Canada have them does it
have many rules about immigration and
certainly it does but this sort of
welcoming culture focused on integration
well it's pretty rare to finds
[Music]
in fact since 1977 every Canadian
citizen can hold any other nationality
without restrictions so when someone
emigrates to Canada and after some years
they can obtain their Canadian passport
they don't have to renounce their
previous nationality but if something
might perfectly show Canada's spirits
well that would be Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau hi everyone was Rockland mall
I'm Justin true
[Music]
justin trudeau a political star just
intraday he took office in 2015 almost
by surprise and at just 44 years vain
today he is one of the most popular
politicians in the world and that's true
in Canada as well this is something that
the polls clearly show a recent survey
by abacus data on the leadership of the
prime minister shows that 70 percent of
Canadians are confident that Trudeau
will successfully manage Canada's
relations with its allies sixty-three
percent trust his responsibility to make
decisions and 62 percent believe that
his decisions will be good ones I mean
how many politicians around the world
would really like approval ratings like
those we need a leader
however Trudeau he's not a typical
politician not at all the Prime Minister
of Canada has put on a table a program
and a form of government that's really
quite different from what's typically
being used and when you look at his
cabinet I mean it's a realistic sample
of Canada's reality a cabinet that looks
like Canada 15 of the 30 ministers are
women
there's even an Afghanistan veteran and
an individual who is formerly a
volunteer in Niger
there are also business executives and
even some ministers who are Sikhs which
is a religion native to the Punjab state
in India by the way has been Ahmed
Hassan a Somali who arrived to Canada as
a refugee at 16 years old and is now the
Minister of immigration plea amazing
right
Trudeau's political priorities well
there is international has his cabinet
one of the governments of canada's key
challenges is to boost trade among
nations now pay attention to that
foreign affairs minister rising trade
barriers hurt the people they are
intended to help they curb growth stifle
innovation and kill employment this is a
lesson we should learn from history this
is why Trudeau wants to sign a free
trade agreements even with China
secondly unlike other governments
Trudeau doesn't just reject
protectionism but he wants to stimulate
a productive change with artificial
intelligence and automation
I mean why hinder technology if there's
something we've seen as history has
progressed is that tech
nology improves people's lives and to
creates more jobs now it might not seem
that something like that is too
complicated to do but the reality is
that there are not many world leaders
who defend this pro-technology position
talking about jobs giving away it's not
exactly a popular line the other great
challenge and maybe the key value of
Trudeau's government's is their best
form boosting civil rights and turning
Canada into an international example of
how this should be done take a look at
the power of this picture Trudeau has
become the first Prime Minister to lead
an LGBTQ Pride Parade there's also the
most recently released program canada's
feminist international assistance policy
yeah you heard that right Trudeau's
government didn't hesitate do you
declare itself feminists and among other
things they have decided to focus most
of their international cooperation
budgets on pushing women's rights where
they are most needed now this it's just
a symbol that sometimes symbols they're
pretty important other symbols and
gestures are is positioned towards
Syrian refugees and pay close attention
to this speech in recent months
Canadians have opened their hearts and
their arms to families fleeing the
ongoing conflict in Syria and from the
moment they arrived those 31 thousand
refugees were welcomed not as burdens
but as neighbors and friends as new
Canadians to date 40,000 Syrian refugees
have arrived in Canada almost half of
them thanks to the sponsorship of
Canadian citizens have committed to be
responsible and looking after their
wellness this is a great example of
solidarity but hey I mean it's one thing
being kind and generous and well it's
quite another to be naive but consider
this the Canadian government has
announced its intention to increase
military spending by more than 70
percent from now until 2024 in order to
create a more agile and modern Armed
Forces
[Music]
trains doors open to technology
integration civil rights security all
these things don't sound bad at all
right especially if you consider that
this government understands the before
starting to discuss spending you have to
talk about wealth creation well I mean
that's how Canada has reached its one
hundred and fiftieth anniversary
everything bloody marvelous right well
wait a second I mean not exactly there
are certainly some shadows but we're
actually gonna have to leave those for
another video something we're probably
gonna call the dark side of Canada don't
think that it's all just rainbows and
butterflies in Canada certainly not not
at all well so do not forget to
subscribe to our channel so you don't
miss that video and well that will allow
you to hear the other side of the story
and now we'd like to know your opinion
what do you think of Trudeau you can
leave us your comments below and also by
clicking on a survey on the screen now
and do not forget to check out our
friends at the reconsider Media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]